no hay rastro del VIH ni en su sangre ni
en su tejido este fue el hallazgo que la
revista nature publicó en un comunicado
este lunes es el tercer caso de cura del
virus que produce el SIDA se trata de un
hombre de 53 años de dusseldorf Alemania
que prefirió permanecer anónimo al
conocer la noticia los dos casos de
éxito anteriores fueron en Berlín en
2009 y en Londres en 2019 y ahora
anunciamos un tercer caso que es la
paciente de tussol es un caso que
también se integra en el equipo icem y
donde
hemos hecho un trasplante hematológico
con células madre de un donante que
tiene una mutación especial Que impide
que el virus penetre en las células Esto
hace que se reconstituya un nuevo
sistema inmunitario y Esto hace que el
virus no pueda penetrar en las células
porque le falta precisamente una puerta
de entrada una proteína que es esencial
para que penetre dentro de la célula del
virus
Y es que los tres pacientes tenían algo
en común padecían de cáncer de sangre y
fueron tratados con un trasplante de
médula que renovó casi por completo su
sistema inmune pero los científicos
dicen que no se podría aplicar el mismo
procedimiento en todos los casos Pues el
trasplante de médula es un proceso
complicado y peligroso y muchas veces
está disponible solo para un pequeño
número de pacientes sin embargo para uno
de los tres hombres sanos se trata de un
suceso que hay que celebrar los últimos
40 años en el desarrollo de una cura
para el VIH la prueba viva de eso soy yo
que a pesar de que ya no tengo VIH sigo
y seré siempre miembro de la comunidad
VIH
porque son sobrevivientes como cáncer
son sobrevivientes del VIH aparte de los
tres pacientes confirmados de Berlín
Londres y dusseldorf hay otros dos casos
de remisión de VIH pendientes para un
trasplante uno de Nueva York y otro de
California Estados Unidos quienes
podrían también tener a la ciencia de su
lado y cantar Victoria en la batalla
contra el sida